I'm so frustrated because of my dad.
He was watching TV and I asked him a question,...
...but he couldn't hear me!
In my opinion, men can't do two things at the same time.
I guess men are just wired differently.
Women can do multiple things at the same time!
For example, I can talk on the phone, watch TV, cook something, answer the door if the doorbell rings...
...all at the same time!
Hmm, actually, you've got something there.
My dad is the same way;...
...I guess I'm the same way too, as far as that goes.
Anyway, it's wonderful that you can multitask.
It seems to me that men and women use different parts of their brains.
Or maybe some parts of the brain are more developed in women than in men, or vice versa.
There is nothing you can do about it!
Men can only do one thing at a time.